thanks to endo Chino for keeping legal
eagle in the air and helping me look fly
if you were taking bets on what
President Trump would do after being
acquitted of impeachment in the Senate
and you said meddle in the affairs of
the Department of Justice in a way that
would make Richard Nixon blush well you
win yay as you probably know Attorney
General Barr has begun overtly inserting
himself into the DOJ cases that directly
affect the president that interference
cost for prosecutors at the DOJ to
withdraw from the case of Roger stone
and one resign from the DOJ entirely
this is not normal its Nixon's Saturday
night massacre if AG Richardson and
deputy AG Ruggles House hadn't resigned
in protest
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because with every passing day
there are fewer and fewer good lawyers
at the Department of Justice on this
episode of what the crap is going on
with the Justice Department we're gonna
take a look at the current debacle
involving the DOJ president Trump AG bar
and Judge Amy Berman Jackson as it
pertains to the sentencing of former
Trump campaign adviser Roger stone jr.
because the rule of law is at stake here
it's hard to overestimate just how crazy
this whole situation is so how did we
get here
well last November the self-proclaimed
Machiavellian Richard Nixon loving Roger
stone jr. was convicted in federal court
on seven counts including one count of
obstruction of proceeding five counts of
making false statements and one count of
witness tampering seriously someone
needs to explain to me how this guy is
not starring in the next Batman movie as
the super villain penguin he's
definitely got the look on Monday
February 10th prosecutors from the
Department of Justice submitted their
recommendation for Roger stones
sentencing after he had already been
convicted of seven different felonies
now often prosecutors will offer a more
lenient sentence in exchange for a plea
bargain and not having to go through the
trouble of actually going through the
trial Roger stone wanted to roll the
dice and went through the entire trial
which resulted in his convictions as a
result the Department of Justice
requested a sentence within the federal
sentencing guidelines of between 7 & 9
years but what happened next can only be
described
bananas because apparently upon seeing
the recommended sentence by the DOJ the
president violated a norm that says that
a president should not comment on
ongoing criminal prosecutions and fired
off the tweet saying this is a horrible
and very unfair situation the real
crimes were on the other side as nothing
happens to them
cannot allow this miscarriage of justice
in less than 24 hours after the initial
sentencing recommendation and the
subsequent Trump tweet the four line
prosecutors at the DOJ who were handling
the stone case withdrew from the case
and one actually resigned from the
Department of Justice while new
prosecutors handling this case at the
DOJ claimed that they made a decision
prior to the Trump tweet they submitted
a supplemental amended sentencing
memorandum recommending a lighter
sentence
in doing so they stated that the initial
sentencing recommendation filed the day
before does not accurately reflect the
Department of Justice's position on what
would be a reasonable sentence in this
matter and I don't know if I can
adequately convey to you how crazy this
is or what it must feel like to be one
of those DOJ prosecutors imagine
yourself a respected Department of
Justice lawyer who just made a
sentencing recommendation to a federal
judge you're looking good in your endo
Chino suit you spent at least a year on
this case you took it to trial and you
won and the sentencing recommendation
was vetted by your boss and your boss's
boss and it was within the federal
guidelines yet just hours after you file
your recommendation with the court the
big boss the political boss comes in and
says you're months of work on the case
don't matter at all and your
recommendation is wrong and the
president even weighs in on how bad your
original work product is you can imagine
that these prosecutors are pissed and
initially people were wondering if this
was a political hatchet job and if bill
bar or the president was responsible for
it and then the president tweeted to
confirm that it was both political and
that bill Barr was responsible for it
the tweets from the president kept
coming applauding Attorney General Bill
Barr in condemning judge Amy Berman
Jackson and the foreperson for the stone
trial all of this with the actual
sentencing date imminently approaching
and Trump's constant tweets about the
matter undercut the Department of
Justice's position that it made the
decision to reverse itself on this
same recommendation without any
intervention from President Trump so why
is this such a big deal well the
Department of Justice and the FBI are
law enforcement agencies that
theoretically operate outside of the
political influence from the White House
now of course the President appoints the
Attorney General and often the US
Attorney's but in the American system of
government the president is not
empowered to use the FBI and DOJ for
political purposes or to save his
cronies from punishment the controversy
over the stone sentencing is the latest
in a series of events that is
potentially eroding the independence of
the Department of Justice and coloring
their actions with the political pen so
before we get into the sentencing Fiasco
here's a quick primer on Roger stone and
the charges and conviction that led to
the current implosion going on at the
DOJ right now now Roger stone as you may
know is a Republican advisor that has
been around since the campaign days of
Richard Nixon he's played roles in
several campaigns some successful follow
Ronald Reagan and some not so much like
Bob Dole Stone is to put it mildly a
character Stone once told The New Yorker
it's rare that I'm accused of something
that I'm not guilty of the
self-described dirty trickster was most
recently a former adviser to President
Trump last year stone was arrested on
charges of obstruction of justice giving
false statements and witness tampering
that all stemmed from findings of
special counsel Robert mullahs probe
into the Russian election interference
specifically these charges related to
his efforts to provide the Trump
campaign with inside information from
WikiLeaks about hacked emails and his
subsequent lying about it to the House
Intelligence Committee during Stone's
trial the DOJ showed that the Trump
campaign was told in April of 2016 that
WikiLeaks had the ability to hack email
accounts of Hillary Clinton her campaign
chair John Podesta the do-si and other
government email accounts and it was
subsequently confirmed that stone was
interacting and negotiating with
WikiLeaks head honcho Julian Assange
Stone spoke with senior Trump campaign
officials about WikiLeaks and quote
information it might have had that would
be damaging to the Clinton campaign and
senior campaign officials later a stone
about any future releases from WikiLeaks
various statements by stone including
many public ones raise questions about
whether he had some sort of inside
knowledge about WikiLeaks or its plans
he denied having any such knowledge and
claimed that anything that he did know
about WikiLeaks came through
an intermediary radio host Randy credit
Co although it was ultimately proven
that the information was coming from
conservative author and conspiracy
theorist jerome corsi ultimately the
charges and conviction focused on stones
alleged lies to the House Intelligence
Committee during 2017 about his efforts
to get in touch with WikiLeaks during
the campaign in addition stone was
convicted of trying to tamper and
intimidate a witness credit Co to ensure
that he would either stick to a false
narrative or plead the fifth in fact at
one point stone suggested that those
testifying regarding the WikiLeaks
information should pull a Frank
Pentangeli to prevent contradicting
stones earlier testimony which relates
to the Godfather because of course it
does and stone was no mere coffee boy
during Stone's trial the government
admitted for the first time the stone
may have discussed WikiLeaks with Donald
Trump during the summer of 2016 in fact
Rick gates testified that he was in a
limousine with trump on their way to
LaGuardia Airport when Trump talked on
the phone with stone about two hacked
emails this information was apparently
redacted from the Mullen report and was
not made public until the stone trial it
directly contradicts Trump's statement
to Robert Muller that quote I did not
recall discussing WikiLeaks with stone
nor do I recall being aware of mr. stone
having discussed WikiLeaks with
individuals associated with my campaign
so we can assume that stone has a lot of
information about President Trump that
the president may not want to become
public leading some to speculate that
regardless of what sentence is handed
down to stone he will avoid substantial
jail time specifically because he knows
so much damaging information about
president Trump likely through a
presidential pardon so Roger stone was
convicted of all charges on November 15
2019 leading to the crucial sentencing
phase that were in right now as with
other cases prior to the pending
sentencing hearing the prosecutors for
the DOJ prepared a memorandum giving
their sentencing recommendation to the
judge government prosecutors based their
sentencing recommendations on the United
States Sentencing Guidelines for the
offenses of conviction in the
recommendation the prosecutors explained
the reasoning for the government
sentencing suggestion prosecutors took a
hard line on stone because in addition
to lying under oath obstructing
Congress's investigation into Russian
interference the 2016 election and
witness tampering stone showed a total
contempt
or the court and the legal system the
original sentencing memorandum states
but when his crimes were revealed by the
indictment in his case he displayed
contempt for this court and the rule of
law for that he should be punished in
accord with the advisory guidelines the
memorandum highlights the facts that
were fleshed out in stones trial
including the Trump's campaign team
believed that stone was providing them
with non-public information about
WikiLeaks plans and with reference to
the testimony before the House
Intelligence Committee the memorandum
states that stone told the committee
five categories of lies those lies were
designed to conceal stones
communications with course I credit co
and the Trump campaign about WikiLeaks
in 2016 and a crucial factor for the
sentencing recommendation and perhaps
the straw that broke the do J's back was
that the crimes committed by stone
involved violence or the threat of
violence the sentencing memorandum
highlights a few key instances where
this was evident for instance on April
9th 2018 in email chain about stones
testimony stone wrote to his alleged
intermediary credit Co quote I'm going
to take that dog away from you not a
thing you can do about it either because
you are a weak broke piece of stone also
told credit go to quote prepare to die
although credit co-state he didn't
believe that stone would steal his dog
or hurt him directly he didn't say that
he was worried about other people
getting ideas if stone posted the
message directly which is the idea
behind stochastic terrorism now all of
these facts resulted in a guideline
recommended sentence of seven to nine
years and it's true the prosecutors have
discretion for proposed sentences but
government prosecutors don't make
arbitrary sentencing recommendations
they're required to use the federal
sentencing guidelines which themselves
were a response to wildly different
sentences being handed down by federal
judges often based on race rather than
criminal severity so the federal
sentencing guidelines are a non-binding
set of rules that set out a uniform
sentencing policy for defendants
convicted in the federal court system
judges can disregard those sentencing
guidelines but often they're seen as
prima facie reasonable a defendant's
sentence is determined by many different
factors ranging from his subjective
guilt to how harmful his actions were to
the actors involved about getting too
bogged down in the details when you're
using the sentence
guidelines you first create a base level
which is predetermined based on the
actual convictions then that level can
either be increased or decreased due to
specific offense characteristics here
the original DOJ sentencing memorandum
increased stones base level based in
part on the threats of violence that
were issued the memorandum stated that
pursuant to the sentencing guidelines
eight levels should be added because the
offense quote involves causing or
threatening to cause physical injury to
a person or property damage in order to
obstruct the administration of justice
in supporting their position the
memorandum noted the standard applied in
previous federal cases for example in US
vs. Plumlee the court held that quote to
apply the enhancement there is no
additional seriousness requirement
beyond the fact of a violent threat and
thus with the crimes that stone was
convicted of and the threat of violence
used in the commission of those crimes
the Justice Department came to a
recommendation of seven to nine years
and although the president and his
advocates think that the sentencing
recommendation is excessive it's in line
with how the DOJ views threats and
witness tampering stones crimes are
exactly the kind of offenses that strike
at the heart of the justice system
blocking investigations lying under oath
and threatening witnesses are all mob
like tactics meant to subvert justice
rather than advance the truth and when
it comes to threatening witnesses with
violence DOJ usually recommends harsher
sentences regardless of whether the
victim feels like the threat is credible
or not especially under circumstances
where the defendant doesn't want to
plead out for a lighter sentence and
forces the government to go through the
trial and as many advocates of criminal
justice reform have pointed out federal
sentences can be very harsh sometimes
draconian and it would be great if there
was across-the-board reform to maybe
tweak some of those sentences and maybe
ratchet down some of the sentencing
guidelines
it just seems really bad when the only
people who get that kind of reduction in
sentences are Friends of the President
so back to the story at hand one day and
one presidential tweet later an amended
and supplemental memorandum was
shockingly submitted by the Justice
Department this just doesn't happen the
new memorandum makes only a passing
mention to the government's previous
recommendation in the case which was
filed less than 24 hours earlier the new
filing only says that its prior sentence
recommendation
does not accurately reflect the
Department of Justice's position on what
would be a reasonable sentence in this
matter in the new amended memorandum the
government declined to make a specific
recommendation beyond saying that
incarceration was appropriate the
sentencing length of the new MO reads
should be left to the judges discretion
the government defers to the court as to
what specific sentence is appropriate
under the facts and circumstances of
this case the filing was signed by John
Crabb jr. the acting chief of the
Criminal Division in the DC US
Attorney's Office who entered in his
appearance in the case minutes before
the memo was filed in justifying the do
J's newfound position the memorandum
states that although stone allegedly had
threatened witness credit COEs therapy
dog Bianca saying that he was booked
going to take that dog away from you it
was important to recognize that credit
Co a New York radio host has
acknowledged that he quote never in any
way felt that stone himself posed a
direct physical threat to me or my dog
essentially what this comes down to is
that the revised memorandum argues that
there was never really any threat of
physical violence as a results the
previous memorandum is supposedly
misguided and quote if the court were
not to apply the 8-level enhancement for
threatening a witness with physical
injury it would result in the defendant
receiving an advisory guideline range of
37 to 46 months which is more in line
with a typical sentences imposed in
obstruction cases end quote it goes on
to urge the judge to consider stones
advanced age health personal
circumstances and lack of criminal
history in fashioning an appropriate
sentence and it's true that both
sentencing recommendations could in fact
be reasonable the DOJ did not have to
move for the enhancement based on the
witness threatening but by the same
token it was totally reasonable for them
to move forward with that enhancement
based on the threatening the fact that
reasonable Minds can disagree about the
original sentence highlights the fact
that it's probably political
intervention seeking a less harsh
sentence for a compete reott of the
president and the results speak for
themselves and highlight how unusual
this was the revised memorandum led to
the shocking withdrawal of four career
US attorneys with one outright resigning
from his job this led to backlash from
within Congress especially for members
of the House Intelligence Committee who
stone lied to representative Adam Schiff
the California Democrat who was the lead
prosecutor in Trump's impeachment trial
said that quote if reports are correct
the Department of Justice and attorney
general bill Barr are poised to overrule
career prosecutors who made a sentencing
recommendation yesterday following a
midnight tweet from the president
attacking the proposed length of the
sentence bar of course defends his
position and argued it was quote
preposterous to characterize his role in
the stone sentencing recommendation as
an intervention he argued that he was
simply attempting to resolve an internal
department dispute this of course is
poppycock because any internal DOJ
dispute about the stone sentencing would
have been settled before the first memo
was filed in other words DOJ lawyers are
supposed to be consummate professionals
filing a memo on Monday and backtracking
24 hours later is amateur hour that you
really don't see from the Department of
Justice and this is not the first time
that president Trump's DOJ has pulled
the rug out from its own attorneys in
front of a federal judge if you recall
last year in the midst of the battle
over adding a citizenship question to
the 2020 census the Justice Department
tried to withdraw and replace its legal
team with no explanation
the DOJ filed motions in two courts
seeking to remove its own lawyers from
the cases two federal judges denied the
do Jay's motions and the inference was
clear there was significant turmoil
amongst the attorneys at the Justice
Department who didn't want to lie to
federal judges about whether they could
or could not include a citizenship
question in the census and so now all of
the attention is on these four line
prosecutors who are career attorneys for
the government even President Trump for
that matter tweeted who are the four
prosecutors Muller people who cut and
ran after being exposed for recommending
a ridiculous nine year prison sentence
to a man that got caught up in an
investigation that was illegal
the Muller scam and shouldn't ever even
have started 13 angry Democrats question
mark well let's answer that question
these four people are a group of Ivy
league-educated prosecutors with some
noteworthy bullet points on their
curriculum vitae reports are that these
four prosecutors have no history of
political contributions in the last 10
years my contacts at the DOJ say that
all of these people were extremely
well-liked and hyper competent so the
situation at the Department of Justice
can only be described as dire career
prosecutors are being overruled by
Attorney General
with little to no explanation and what
appears to be overtly political reasons
on the face of it the President of the
United States is attacking the DOJ
lawyers during his nightly Twitter time
and judges are criticizing the
government's position and now AG bar has
admitted to bringing in a team of
Midwestern lawyers to review and reverse
determinations made by DOJ prosecutors
on national security cases that may
implicate the president as David
Loughman a former senior Justice
Department official said the move was
quote a shocking cramdown political
intervention in the criminal justice
process we are now truly at a break
glass in case of fire moment for the
Justice Department of course there are
those on the president's defense arguing
that this is just a plot by prosecutors
linked to the Muller probe to legitimize
their now defunct Russian election
interference investigation but with
hints at a potential pardon and
congratulatory tweets coming from the
president stating congratulations to
Attorney General Bill Bar for taking
charge of a case that was totally out of
control and perhaps should not have even
been brought evidence now clearly shows
that the Muller scam was improperly
brought and tainted even Bob Muller lied
to Congress even the president's own
allies and those close to the situation
are asking the president to show a
little restraint attorney general Barr
is going to testify in front of Congress
at the end of March but he appeared on
ABC for an interview saying I cannot do
my job here at the department with a
constant background commentary that that
undercuts me to have public statements
and tweets made about the department
about people in the department are men
and women hear about cases pending in
the department and about judges before
whom we have cases make it impossible
for me to do my job and to assure the
courts and the prosecutors in the in the
department that we're doing our work
with integrity Barr suggested that the
president wasn't involved and that he
made the decision on his own but that
ignores the fact that this action
clearly benefits the president and is
what the president wants so that really
doesn't clear the air in any meaningful
way and some have lauded bill bar for
breaking with the president and
suggesting that the Department of
Justice is independent but based on the
president's
action or non reaction saying that bill
bar can do whatever he wants I think
this is more likely just political
theater as commentator quinta Jurassic
put it this is kayfabe in other words
what they do in professional wrestling
where they appear to have fights when
they're really just all friends at the
end it appears to be political
subterfuge and president Trump sensibly
backs this up by tweeting in the
alternative that he hasn't interfered
but that he has the right to do so which
is worrying he tweets the president has
never asked me to do anything in a
criminal case this doesn't mean that I
do not have as president the legal right
to do so I do but I have so far chosen
not to of course none of this is
happening in a vacuum all of these
shenanigans are going on less than a
week after Trump was acquitted by the
Senate on impeachment charges in that
short time the administration has
dismissed former national security
adviser Lieutenant Colonel Alexander bin
Minh and former US ambassador to the
European Union Gordon Sunland both of
whom testified before the House
Intelligence Committee impeachment
hearings at the same time Jesse Lew the
ex US attorney that oversaw the original
Roger stone case has resigned from the
Trump administration after the Trump
administration removed her nomination
for a top job at the Treasury Department
and if we're looking for historical
precedent there is one that jumps out
this whole situation is reminiscent of
the infamous Saturday night massacre
when then President Nixon ordered his
Attorney General and Deputy Attorney
General to fire special prosecutor
Archibald Cox during the whole Watergate
scandal they resigned and the reluctant
Solicitor General Robert Bork ultimately
handled Nixon's requests is Bill Barr
Trump's Robert Bork some would say yes
but AG bar seems anything but reluctant
to comply with Trump's demands here on
this channel we try to have fun with the
law in the news and we also try to be
fair and balanced about the events as
they unfold but I can't really sugarcoat
this situation things are very bad here
in Washington even people who have
worked with Barr are sounding the alarm
former deputy AG Donald Ayer served in
the administration of George HW Bush and
has known bar for over 40 years and said
I don't think he's fit for the office
because I think what he's done is to
undertake a campaign essentially to
undermine the Department of Justice as
of the time of this filming Oh
were 2,000 former DOJ lawyers have
called on bar to step down of course
he's not going to but condemnation from
career justice employee shows the
severity of this crisis the former
employees wrote that quote a person
should not be given special treatment in
criminal prosecution because they are a
close political ally of the president
governments that use the enormous power
of law enforcement to punish their
enemies and reward their allies are not
constitutional republics they are
autocracies and it's not just former DOJ
lawyers either it's the judges as well a
National Association of federal judges
which includes over a thousand federal
judges and there aren't that many
federal judges has called an emergency
meeting to discuss political
interference in criminal prosecutions
this isn't normal okay quick update the
news never sleeps and I am coming to you
from VidCon London I was going to
release this video today but Roger stone
was sentenced so we know the outcome to
what happened here in this particular
sentencing hearing the judge excoriated
the DOJ she just went after them for
basically engaging in political
misconduct as she confirmed that the DOJ
originally had the US Attorney for the
District of DC to confirm the sentence
they talked to main justice and it was
approved and John Crabb the acting US
Attorney here confirmed that there was
some sort of misunderstanding though he
wouldn't explain what that
misunderstanding was after that after
the judge excoriated the DOJ the judge
engaged in her own calculation which a
federal judge is wanted to do she
accepted some of the enhancements and
rejected others she deviated slightly
from the guidelines and the judges are
not bound by the federal sentencing
guidelines in the kind of deviation that
she engaged in is totally normal so the
end of the story is that Roger stone got
three years and four months in jail 40
months in jail and he will serve that
time unless he is pardoned so back to
devin of the past to explain the
repercussions of this particular hearing
and sentencing so here's what we know
for certain Roger stone is going to jail
probably but for the man who bragged
about his stones rules and that it quote
is better to be infamous than never to
be famous at all
well mission
sir and second he's going to be wearing
an orange jumpsuit for the foreseeable
future though it's possible he might get
a presidential pardon and while stone
suit game is usually on point I doubt
any of those penguin desk suits are
going to fit when he finally gets out of
federal prison
so Roger when you get out of prison and
need to replace all your old suits I
can't recommend indogene Oh highly
enough especially if you want a
custom-built slim cut suit suits are
looking a little bit baggy all of my
suits are now made by Indochine Oh
including this awesome brown checked
three-piece that I'm wearing right now
because when you're talking about Roger
stone you have to bring your a-game see
the secret to a great suit is all about
the fit and I'm a reasonably athletic
guy and I can never buy suits off the
rack because they simply never fit right
and plus they're crazy expensive if the
shoulders fit the waist is too small it
either doesn't fit right or it costs an
arm and a leg to get a tailor to fix it
but with Indo Chino you can send in your
measurements online using the link in
the description or you can go to one of
their hundreds of stores across the
country and have a stylist take your
measurements personally for myself I
made an appointment I went to the store
in person and a stylist worked with me
for over ninety minutes when I went in
for the first time my personal stylist
took my measurements and a couple of
weeks later I got the best fitting suit
of my entire life and the best part is I
can just reorder and reorder using those
exact measurements and know that I'm
going to get a great suit every single
time they're perfect right out of the
box
Indochina will make you a fully custom
suit tailored specifically for you for
less than $400 and the best part is they
still use the best materials like super
140 s wool in fact legal eagles can get
any premium Indo Chino suit for just
three hundred and fifty nine dollars if
you use the link in the description you
can customize it exactly how you want
and get it made specifically for your
individual body and nobody else I will
never get an off-the-rack suit again and
once you try it neither will you legal
eagles can get any premium Indo Chino
suit for just three hundred and fifty
nine dollars when you use the promo code
legal eagle at checkout or use the link
in the description so use the link below
to get the best custom suit of your
entire life do you agree with my
analysis leave your objections in the
comments and check out this playlist
over here for all of my other real law
reviews where I talk about all of the
legal issues that are in the news so
click on this link and I'll see you in
court